die
easy
rennt
monka w
ja da bin ich wieder ich weiß nicht wie lange ich heute
jetzt nerven die einen schon im inkognito modus was soll der scheiß alter twitch gehen wir nicht
was machen die denn ich will einfach den chat sehen alter ohne mich einzuloggen ist das so ist
es wirklich so viel verlangt ok habt ihr noch eine glorreiche idee wie wir das fixen können dass
ich den chat mir angucken kann ohne ohne mich einloggen zu alter man sieht jetzt seriously man
sieht wirklich nichts ernsthaft man braucht jetzt ein konto um den chat zu sehen ist das schlecht
ist das schlecht man man erkennt halt nix chatterino geht das auch geht das überhaupt noch jetzt
geht ab das da das da was lebt man da runter das hier das ist das richtige oder das ist das
richtige gibt es das gibt es das auch stand alone so einfach zipp und entpacken und gut ist
jubantu app image windows ja gut wir können das ja auch können das ja auch in der vm machen da
spricht eigentlich nix dagegen moin wie war das gespräch mit dem alt chef ja ging glaube ich
halbe stunde war war nicht was war nicht sonderlich will chat ein bisschen sachen wissen was ich
schon gemacht habe und ich finde es ja eigentlich eine ganz gute idee dass man als als chef chef
chef also von von so einer von so einem laden wenn ich aber immerhin doch hat relativ viele
leute da unter sich dass man so mal die neuen leute gesehen haben will und so was finde ich
eigentlich gar nicht schlecht besser als im alten laden wo ich gewesen bin wo ich von unserem it
chef quasi in zehn jahren zweimal was gehört habe oder sowas moment ich muss mein wallpaper
wallpaper script laufen lassen extra leute sonnenuntergang pepo happy am start so muss
das sein exzellente hintergründe exzellente exzellente extrem lieb ich bin da wieder
um so als wir es ist jeterino jeterino kleint ab image nightly
jitter jeterino was ist die letzte version 242 was hatten da hat sie irgendwas gute
bewertung mit 7 tv support hat er standart kein 7 tv support
das war jetzt einfach dass das app image runter und startet das image
gibi portable haben wir auch downloads plus x jeterino ok zeigt man ja wie das
von split und wie mache ich da jetzt den channel auf weil ich habe das ding noch nie benutzt wie
verwendet wie tritt man hier irgendwas empty das klick das join a twitch channel by its name
wubbelortz hey warum warum ist das so dunkel ist das normal dass das so aussieht als wäre
das inaktives fenster ach ne weil das chat history ist ach so ah ja ja alles klar das
war kurz klein im kleinen emote check machen funktioniert doch alles oder
alles so haben wir doch unseren haben wir doch unseren chat geht doch kann man den kammer
diesen krempel hier oben noch
kann man diesen krempel hier oben noch ausblenden interface
kam weiß jemand ob man ich meine ich kann einfach fullscreen machen das
ne das geht doch aber ist nicht gut man das nicht ausplöten hier oben popup ne wirklich
was jetzt
ans trinken erinnert ja müsste nicht müsste nicht ich habe ich habe hier vor mir stehen
erst jetzt ja aus den bots der immer joint wenn ich online komme kann man irgendwie das aus
plennt ich glaube ich glaube die die obox kann man nicht ausblenden die zeile aber es
doch ok dann gucken wir uns jetzt halt nicht hier im chat an weil twitch halt der meinung
ist das geht nicht wobei habe ich auch da war das hier weg zack zack
so ich krieg mein eigenes video empfohlen stimmt ja gar nicht lull besondere technik
gadgets unter 50 ok lass mich raten das kostet alles 49 euro und es ist allerwichtigste dass
es abgerundete ecken hat und ein bisschen nach apple design aussieht wie sinnvoll das ist
das immer noch diese shorts mann
elemente ausrichten in powerpoint oh ja leute das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen wie man
richtig elemente in powerpoint ausrichtet warum kann man nicht elemente einfach mit css ausrichten
also ich meine da hat man wenigstens reproduzierbaren weg wie man nicht weiß dass es funktioniert
should you buy in japan ja weiß ich nicht was ich was ich bein sollte ja was sollte man
für 3d-drucker bein oder ich weiß nicht wie lange durch halt ich bin übelst müde aber ich
dachte mir guck mal es ist 20 22 ich kann ja nichts wirklich sinnvolles mal machen zwei stunden
das schwätzt mir lieber noch mal eine runde heute war wirklich anstrengend ich bin heute
aufgestanden um ja also kurz vor so ungefähr um sieben sagen wir mal um sieben bisschen vor
sieben aber ja sieben und ich bin erst um ja ungefähr um 18 uhr wieder im haus gewillen
hier ich meine ich war nicht die ganze zeit auf der arbeit ich bin auf der arbeit ungefähr so
16 uhr weg und ich halt heimgefahren vom hauptbahnhof aus aber ich sage euch ich weiß echt nicht ich
frage mich das immer wieder ich frage mich ernsthaft wie habe ich das geschafft vor
ganz langen zeit als ich noch fünf tage woche gearbeitet habe ja mich ist ich verstehe es nicht
wie schafft man das fünf tage zu arbeiten und jeden tag zwölf stunden unterwegs zu sein
exklusive arbeit geht doch eigentlich gar nicht da bist du kannst doch am wochenende gar nichts
mehr machen weil du so im arsch bist dass einfach zwei tage tage durch schläft und
funktioniert doch eigentlich gar nicht mehr also keine ahnung wie ich das früher gemacht habe
ich wüsste echt nicht mehr wie ich für fünf tage woche aushalten soll so sieht das so ist
was ist denn das für ein chat und warum ganz einfach weil twitch mittlerweile möchte dass
man eingeloggt ist und ich nicht mehr einfach nur den chat aufmachen kann zum reingucken
müssen wir halt auf machen bisschen doof dass man den kram hier oben nicht ausblenden kann also
das wäre fände ich tatsächlich ganz nice weil das brauche ich nicht wirklich
bei den amis ist zwölf stunden lang normal ja bei den amis ist aber auch normal dass man 200
k plus im jahr verdient wenn man in der technologieindustrie ist gut die müssen
dafür auch krankenversicherung selbst bezahlen und machen es nicht und haben dann andere probleme
oder aber was auch bei den amis passieren kann du klingelst an der falschen tür und
wirst einfach erschossen ja hell yeah so muss das anscheinend sein
die amis arbeiten auch anders wieso wir arbeiten die anders
hat das gelesen bei den amis ist irgendein typ ich habe so in so einem ticker in so einem
news ticker gesehen letztens ein amis ist irgendein typ an die falsche haustür gegangen hat geklingelt
hat er typ die haustür aufgemacht hat ihn erschossen weil er war ja auf seinem grundstück und da ist
das ist das ok ja das stimmt naja gut das ist das ist in den ganzen das ist in den
ganzen videos so ja das stimmt schon aber leute also das machen ja da auch immer mehr nicht ja
immer mehr haben da auch kein bock auf 24 24 7 arbeitskleid was wir kennen ist halt das
das waren das eben leute was ist
was bin ich sehend hier
da kann man chattery noch irgendwie splitten oder sowas
denn bin
überrated das nicht sein wir sind da
ja vor jetzt sagen
ach keine Ahnung
wie ist das morgens eigentlich an diesem eland haufe frankfurt hauptbahnhof lang zu laufen ich
laufe unkern los frage frankfurt hauptbahnhof ist wirklich so richtige drecksecke also du hast
so viel fertige leute da und das ist morgens auch so viel los und so eng die leute husten
vor sich hin und halten husten nicht an und oder keine ahnung oder rotzen irgendwie auf
der erde rum und kotzen teilweise rum ich habe leute schon gesehen in die ecke gekackt haben
also frankfurt hauptbahnhof ist wirklich aber nicht also wenn ich die ich laufe lieber also
ich fahre lieber zum südbahnhof und laufe vom willi brandplatz ein stückchen anstatt zum hauptbahnhof
zu fahren ja naja gut wie gesagt keine ahnung wie ich das früher fünf tage in die woche
durchgehalten ab in den frankfurt frankfurt hauptbahnhof ist wirklich shit also ganz ehrlich
jedes mal wenn ich frankfurt hauptbahnhof muss denke ich mir was machst du hier richtig richtig
richtig dreck singen ich muss sagen auch wenn jetzt viele leute gesagt haben stimmte überhaupt nicht
ist doch viel besser gut kann sein das war nur so momentaufnahme also ich muss sagen als ich aus
hauptbahnhof rausgekommen bin auf tja auf der einen seite ich blicke da nicht durch wo was ist
hat mich tatsächlich ein bisschen an frankfurt erinnert das ist zwar das ist zwar drumherum
deutlich offener ja und auch irgendwie geräumiger als irgendwie frankfurt hauptbahnhof aber sind auch
ganz viele asoziale leute am start gewesen hat mich direkt hat mich direkt instant an frankfurt
hauptbahnhof erinnert als in berlin raus bin aber viele haben jetzt ich hab das ja schon ein paar
mal erzählen viele haben gesagt wachs wachs das stimmt nicht hast den schlechten tag erwischt
anscheinend muss es wohl nicht ganz so schlimm sein also frankfurt hauptbahnhof ist glaube ich
auch echt so mit das mit das abartigste so was es in deutschland gibt an an pannhöfen keine ahnung
ob er jetzt schon echt besser geworden ist muss man sagen also im bahnhof selber ist ja kaum noch
was im bahnhof selbst ist so viel bahn security und teilweise polizei da ist nichts mehr dafür
sobald du halt in schritt rausmachst oder sobald halt in schritt auf die rolltreppe
gehst oder sonst was ist halt sofort hat sie hat sie im prinzip alles raus verlagert aus dem
direkten innenbereich vom hauptbahnhof halt in in in die nebengänge und ja da musste ja irgendwie
musste irgendwie musste ja hin ja und gerade was am hauptbahnhof leute ohne mist also sag ich mal
ganz im ernst wenn ihr hier wenn ihr mal in frankfurt seid ja
aufwärts hauptbahnhof
wir haben keinen da doch wir machen da wieder hat google das haben wir nicht selbst in dark theme
ja gut also wenn ihr mal wenn ihr mal hauptbahnhof sagt ja wenn ihr mal wenn ihr mal hauptbahnhof
sagt also hier vorne ist wirklich immer abartig man kommt ja hier vorne kommt man raus
und normalerweise um irgendwo hin zu kommen laufen die meiste leute hier rüber ja also hier
hier ist der überweg vom hauptbahnhof zu sehen sogar mittlerweile die ampel ampel drauf hier auf
google maps so und hier hier gegenüber hier so in diesem bereich ohne scheißleute was da an
leute rumhängt das sehe ich nicht normal also wenn ihr wenn ihr mal sehen wollt wo ihr nicht
für möglich halt dass es solche leute gibt dann geht hier hin so dieser bereich da gammeln da
gammeln alle rum früher war hier ein automat von der sparkasse glaube ich einen sattel ich weiß
ich ob man das auf sattel sieht ne moment wo sind es hier layers
bin grad so blöd das zu benutzen ja guck hier genau hier ist hier ist im prinzip so auch der
überweg wo die ganzen leute lang stellsten na gut gerade gerade war anscheinend die ampel rot und
hier sieht man es das sieht das sieht mittlerweile ein bisschen anders aus hier ich weiß nicht von
wann das bild ist ist das aktuell ok das ist aktuell ja aber da stehen jetzt ein paar mehr
kisten und so rum aber im prinzip gut vielleicht stehen die auch hier um man sieht von oben nicht
hier leute hier davor hier hier gammeln echt da willst du willst einfach nur ganz schnell weg
ja und hier muss man halt wenn man wenn man irgendwie aus hier laufen auch viele leute
vorbei und das ist halt so und hier gammeln echt die ganzen leute und halt und halt auch in den
ganzen gängen es geht ja irgendwo hier neben runter zum hauptbahnhof ich sehe das von hier
geht es runter zum hauptbahnhof hier neben irgendwo geht es runter zum hauptbahnhof und da gammeln
sie auch hier hier genau hier ist auch der eingang zum hauptbahnhof da gammeln sie auch alle rum aber
hier so diese ecke ist ganz abartig und wo ihr halt auch gucken müsst ist also so direkt vom
hauptbahnhof und hier neben ist halt auch also hier würde ich an eurer stelle nicht unbedingt
großartig langsieh niederstraße moselstraße muss die niederstraße meinser landstraße
nehmen die ist doch auch hier irgendwo ist denn die niederstraße muss eine von diesen elbstraße
muss einer von diesen wo ist denn das muss doch hier irgendwo sein
hier fast hier das ist auch so hier da gammeln da gammeln auch immer alle rum ich glaube auf
der niederstraße ist auch irgendwie die diese drogenausgabe stelle und hier so also ohne scheiß
diese ecke wenn ihr die möglichkeit habt lauft lauft lieber so rum ja kaiserstraße und so ist
vollkommen in ordnung kaiserstraße war früher so die frankfurter puff ecke also hier kaiserstraße
taunostraße taunostraße sind immer noch genug kaiserstraße auch aber mittlerweile hat sich auch
in frankfurt durchgesetzt dass man anscheinend mit rotlicht gar nicht mehr so viel kohle machen kann
wenn denn die gesamte straße ist voll mit friseur supermarkt restaurants revet to go und
sonstigen geschichten also gibt es kaum was ausgerahte flashbacks warum also ja habe ich
schon mal gezeigt ja ja gut kann ja sein oder taunostraße habe ich mal mitgekriegt in überfall
live auf der straße das habe ich aber glaube ich auch schon erzählt über ein überfall die
kannten sich halt die straße lang gelaufen hier also nicht in der taunostraße über die taunostraße
und gegenüber auf der straßenseite laufen laufen zwei mädels als mädels gut 50 jährige oder so
laufen zwei frauen und auf einmal kommt von hinten ein typ an gerannt schlägt der eine gegen den
kopf nimmt ihr das nimmt ihr das das was in der hand hat ab und rennt weg und der hit kam mir
dann danach ich habe ich habe leider vergessen was das für name war nennen wir ihn mal karl ja
nennen wir ihn mal karl und auf einmal schreite dem hinterher karl was machst du denn die kannten
sich die wusste wer das ist der typ ist einfach random auf die straße hat irgendjemand aufs maul
geschlagen hat er das gepäck geklaut und die kannten sich alles gibt es echt nur in dieser
ecke man gut wahrscheinlich hatten dann die polizei auch relativ schnell gefunden aber
ohne scheiß also frankfurt in dieser ecke das ist echt nicht normal ich glaube es gibt in
deutschland ich will nicht sagen weltweit da gibt es bestimmt wobei ich denke dass frankfurt
bahnhof viertel weltweit wirklich gut mit dabei ist in dieser thematik die ich dich jetzt die ich
ich glaube in deutschland sind ist es auf jeden fall die stelle wo es also es gibt
glaube ich in deutschland keine andere stelle wo es so nah beieinander liegt extremst arme
komplett fertige leute zu extrem reichen leuten also frankfurter bahnhof hier so in dieser ecke
kannst du durchaus passieren dass sie der milliardär an dem drogenabhängigen kurz vorm
abkratzen vorbeiläuft also das ist tatsächlich glaube das gibt es nur in frankfurter bahnhof
hier in dieser ecke stell dir mal vor du würdest in der taunostraße wohnen oh nee nee wenn ich
der taunostraße wohnen würde leute da müsste ich da müsste ich jeden tag zum mosel eck weiß
kann ich wo ist das das aus hat man moselleck
was leck warum hat das moselleck so gute bewertung
ich sehe da nur immer die ganzen besoffenen vor umhängen warum hat das so gute bewertung
findet ihr nicht auch dass das mega einladend aussieht
wer will dann nicht rein ich meine beste bewertung warum hat das so gute bewertung
ok für fußballfans ok
das
ok ich hätte nicht gedacht dass das tatsächlich so halbwegs ernste bewertung hat aber ok ich
sehe da immer die besoffenen rumhängen also wenn ihr in frankfurt seid ich kann euch nur den
tipp geben angenommen ihr wollt ihr wollt auf die zeil die zeil ist hier oben irgendwo das da hier
hauptware das ist da wo die ganzen leute hingehen zum einkaufen ich weiß zwar immer noch nicht
genau warum man offline einkaufen gehen sollte aber schön und gut was geht mit dem verkehr ab ja das
ist blödsinnig das ist hier teilweise auch fußgängerzone und also nicht nur das hier
fußgängerzone da ist halt sehr zähflüssig alles da sind sehr viele fußgänger und alle
rennen kreuz und quer also hier ist immer hier ist immer zähflüssig und gerade jetzt 20 30 da
ist hier ist hier voll aber hier fährt auch keiner der noch halbwegs bei verstand ist normalerweise
großartig mit dem auto rum wenn ihr auf die zeil gewollt was viele wollen einkaufen oder römer
und sowas das ist alles in die gleiche richtung hier goethe haus römerberg da gehen da gehen viele
touristen entweder wenn ihr wirklich vom hauptbahnhof das bahnhofsviertel genießen
wollt was tatsächlich manche touristen wollen ich verstehe zwar nicht warum aber es wollen
offensichtlich genug also solltet ihr geht nicht hier raus geht nicht in die richtung auch wenn
es aussieht als taunusstraße die kürzere kürzere weg geht hier unten rum geht über die kaiserstraße
ja da hast du immer noch genug assis und fertige leute aber kaiserstraße geht nicht hier oben
moselstraße taunusstraße niederstraße rum geht hier lang hier könnt ihr im prinzip mehr oder
weniger direkt dann auch hier euro tower vorbei das ist das ist das ist hier wo das wo das wo
das euro zeichen davor steht für die brandplatz ich glaube ist das das nee hier ist das euro
zeichen sieht man kann man konnte man das nicht irgendwie kippen den mist da muss man auf google
dass das funktioniert der genaueste klo bus der welt street view stimmt lasst mal kurz checken ob
es wieder street view überhaupt gibt an der stelle man sieht ja vereinzelt google autos fahren
2009 hier sind sie hier sind sie nicht mal angefangen gut 2009 war das euro war das euro zeichen auch
hallo hallo ich will ich will darum ja hier sieht man das euro zeichen genau wobei das es hat sich
nicht viel verändert leute das also ohne scheiß 2009 und 2023 sieht nahezu identisch aus
bisschen was ich glaube die fenster hier sehen jetzt ein bisschen anders aus und aber die
straßenbahn sehen noch genauso aus und da hier der eingang zu es sieht mehr oder weniger noch
genauso aus ja und gucken wir mal kurz bei google ob das funktioniert ausprobieren frankfurt willi
brandplatz krasser krasser zoom enhance ja guck mal ist was besser wie street view und hier
hier guck mal das hat aber noch eben das hat doch garantiert jemand von hand gemodelt das ding das
hat na wobei nicht übel oder für aus sateliten bildern errechnet nicht übel weil das sieht das
ding sieht nicht wirklich so aus wenn man davor steht aber für aus sateliten bildern errechnet
gar nicht mal übel ja so sieht so sieht so sieht das ding aus also muss sagen ist schon etwas ist
schon etwas detailarm was man hier sieht zumindest könnte er könnte halt hier gut durchlaufen
hier kaiser straße können auch direkt hier weiter laufen dann dann hoch da wo die ganzen
hier touristen irgendwo hin wollen wobei ich auch immer noch nicht verstehe hier so altstadt und
so zeug gehen immer viele hin aber ich verstehe immer noch warum man in frankfurt irgendwie als
tourist was man in frankfurt will so wir sind hier noch voll immer megaviele asiaten und so was
im sommer und ich denke mir halt so riesenstädte mit mit hunderttausend leuten unterwegs haben die
in asien doch fast noch krasser als wir hier in frankfurt wollen die in frankfurt für die
für die paar für die paar häuser altstadt so skyline haben die also wenn die sich skyline
angucken wollen dann können sie auch in asien sich städte angucken aber es hat schon was es
hat was also ich bin ja früher immer hier gelaufen bin ja früher immer üben
ich muss mal kurz checken wo wir sind hoppernhof
spielplatz
da hier bin ich für ist hier das
ist echt so rot alles hier mittlerweile
ich ich kenne mich ich kenne mich selbst nicht mehr aus ne hier bin ich immer rüber hier bin ich
immer rüber genau hier bin ich immer rüber gelaufen und und das hat schon was wenn man
hier drüber läuft ich versuche aber dass irgendwie man das irgendwie sieht wenn man hier drüber
läuft und dann mache ich super und dann so in die richtung guckt es hat schon was ja
es macht schon ein bisschen macht schon ein bisschen was her aber man ist hier also ich bin
hier morgens oft rüber gelaufen da war es noch dunkel gerade im winter und wenn ich hier du
läufst halt von hier drüben du kommst halt von hier unten hier ist nicht viel an großen häusern
in welchem arbeit ist das sage ich sage ich euch nicht so und wenn man dann hier halt die
brücke lang läuft und guckt dann läuft dann so quasi morgens wenn es nachts ist rüber in hier
drauf zu das ist ja alles das ja alles erleuchtet und hell und gelb so gelblich so was mit google
maps ist schon leis das mal kurz schauen ob es auf street view gibt
ja ja gut es ist nicht wirklich nacht aber man kann sich der michael bergt
kann sich so ein bisschen bisschen überlegen wie geht man auf street view wieder aus jetzt
vielleicht noch mehr bilder wo irgendeiner bei nacht aufgenommen hat
ja das gesumme kann man sich
ich finde es hat schon was wenn man hier so drüber läuft hier war übrigens richtig richtig
schönes wetter anscheinend schon irgendwie cool gewesen der roller dude für immer verewigt
hier auf google street ja ist ja nicht street view kennst du apple maps ja aber das habe ich an
install also das ist tatsächlich ganz nice wenn man hier morgens rein läuft nach frankfurt und
sieht dann erst mal die dinger dass ich glaube dass die kommerzbank glaubt es die kommerzbank
ist schon alles was hier am start die internationale fotografie blabla bin interessiert 2021
und hier drüben ob das habe ich auch schon mal erzählt hier drüben wollten wir einer
von der brücke springen wo ich vorbei gelaufen bin ich bin ich bin ich bin gelaufen von von
hier richtung südbahnhof da fehlt was hier bin ich bin ich bin ich vorbei gelaufen oder gucke
ich da gucke ich so nach links und dann steht hier so ein typ hinter der hinter der prüstung
bei irgendwann nachmittags steht so ein typ hinter der prüstung und will von der brücke springen
wo man sich halt fragt so ist er bescheuert ich meine guckt mal dass er hoch ist das nett
es kommt jetzt hier nicht so rüber es ist ein bisschen höher als es hier aussieht aber es ist
jetzt also es ist jetzt wirklich nicht so dass sie dir da groß was tust es sei denn du kannst
nicht schwimmen also könntest denke ich mal wenn du dir mühe gibst ohne probleme von der
brücke springen und die wird absolut gar nichts passiert es ist nicht wirklich hoch
naja so viel so viel zum zum thema frankfurt ja
apple hat den ganz deutschland street view gemacht kappa ja kappa oder nicht kappa haben
sie oder haben sie nicht arbeitest du in einem hochhaus streng genommen nicht ne
also dort wo ich arbeite die haben ein hochhaus aber die haben mehrere standorte und ich bin
keinem hochhaus benutzt ein neues chatprogramm korrekt das ist ein neues chatprogramm weil
twitch der meinung war chat geht nur noch mit anmeldungen
warst du schon mal beim kahn kiosk welcher ist denn das
durchaus möglich also kiosk namen merke ich mir nicht wirklich
ist ist er auf in welcher straße ist er
ganz legendär kenne ich
so ich suche das jetzt mal also wie heißt das
probieren wir gucken wir jetzt mal erst das kann
der kiosk hat einen eigenen eintrag bierhandlung ah ok das ist am südbahnhof das ist das ist am
südbahnhof also richtung richtung südbahnhof ok habe ich mich verguckt ich dachte die dachte
die tech store gasse ist am südbahnhof keine ahnung hier war ich noch nicht ich bin ich bin
verwirrt wo sind wir da ist der hauptbahnhof der südbahnhof ist hier unten keine ahnung
nie war ich war ich noch nie aber hasen glas ich glaube das ist auch fast wo die
wo wir gerne touristen gehen denn es gibt mehrere ja gut ich meine der der name ist jetzt ja auch
recht verbreitet apple ist sogar das einzige das sein haus im wald in der ferne zu sehen ist
aha ich habe apple diese apple maps ab habe ich direkt installiert ich habe die noch nie benutzt
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass sie was taugt ja ich benutze neues chatprogramm weil twitch der
meinung war man muss eingeloggt sein für chat hast du ihm alles gute gewünscht du meinst der
typ an dem ich vorbeigelaufen bin der von der brücke springen wollte ich habe gar nicht zu dem
gesagt ich habe die polizei angeschrieben auf twitter die polizei hat direkt darauf reagiert
über twitter ich habe der polizei frankfurt polizei frankfurt auf wird da geschrieben hier
auf der blabla was auch immer brücke steht einer so quasi hinter der brüstung von der
brücke und wir runterspringen und da hat die polizei mir geantwortet danke für die info
kollegen sind irgendwie sind schon auf dem weg wurden schon informiert oder so was als
hat anscheinend hat anscheinend jemand anderes jemand anderes bescheid gesagt wobei da stand
auch irgendeine die mit dem geredet hat ehrlich ich ich hat es eilig ich muss zum zug soll
auch springen wenn juckts ich kenne den typ nicht time predictions sind deutlich besser mit google
maps ich verwende google maps halt als einzigen als einzigen dieser soll ich verwende google
maps auch zum navigieren das einzige was ich manchmal noch verwende für so traffic reports
und ob irgendwo eben was akutes passiert ist noch ways wobei die ab manchmal rumbackt also
das wissen mittlerweile zum größten teil google google google maps
ich kann auch mal apple maps ausprobieren warum nicht
könnte man doch mal testen also das ist bei ways tatsächlich ganz gut mit den tempo limits aber
das brauche ich nicht weil das ist im auto selbst drinne also das auto hat kartenmaterial
hat verkehrsschilderkennung und hat dann dementsprechend sogar so eine anzeige wie
viel man zu schnell ist und macht sogar blinken wenn man zu schnell fährt also wenn man zu so
und so viel prozent irgendwie zu schnell fährt macht dann da weiß er ok ist gut ein bisschen
langsam kann es kann ja vor allem mal ganz schnell passieren so im unteren
geschwindigkeits segment weil mit dem e auto bis halt wirklich schnell auf 50 plus
haben wir noch irgendwas spannendes was wir auf youtube gucken können ich kann nicht wieder den
ganzen tag schwätzen leute was haben wir denn hier besondere technik gadgets unter 50 euro ok
ich meine vier vier minuten 54 was kann was kann da schon groß passieren
das kann ich mir vorstellen ja ich fahre zwar nachts nicht durch die stadt
aber ja das ist jetzt auch nicht in der stadt so welchen blitzer warner benutzt
du natürlich gar keinen weil das ist verboten wenn man nachts mit dem auto also ja also ich
habe das auch nicht nur nicht nur nachts die probleme und generell mit dem e auto gerade
gerade auch an bahnübergängen und so was und wenn man dann wieder anfährt man ist man ist
sauschnell auf 50 plus also muss ich jedes mal aufpassen deswegen ist es gut dass das auto
verkehrsschilderkennung hat immer gleich macht blim blim wenn man zu schnell ist also wenn
irgendwie so keine ahnung wenn 10 prozent zu schnell bist oder irgendwie so was sagt es dann
sagt es bescheid hier max was fährst du für eine kacke bei uns haben sie letztens in blitzer
angeschmiert hast du auf der auheimer straße bestimmt auch gesehen welche ist das ist das
ja in der kaserne oder ist es hier am hauptbahnhof
ach hier habe ich nicht gesehen
habe ich nicht gesehen das habe ich nicht gesehen aber gut man kommt ja manchmal vor
hast du bequert ne also habe ich ja habe ich man kann irgendwie geschwindigkeit einstellen
aber also ich bin ich weiß nicht ob ich so was wirklich was was wirklich auch okay also ich
habe für die autobahn zum geschwindigkeit halten sowas drin also ich glaube geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung
selbst weiß ich gar nicht ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht ich habe ich habe etwas was akustisch
im auto sagt wenn ich zu schnell bin dann fahre ich halt dann fahre ich langsamer muss ich mal
gucken vielleicht ist er noch da wenn ich das nächste mal vorbei laufe also das einzige was
ich letztens gemerkt habe ist dass tatsächlich dass nicht einfach nur bei mir im handbuch steht
dass bei 150 schluss ist mit dem auto und das habe ich jetzt festgestellt das steht nicht nur
im handbuch das ist auch wirklich so also ich habe letztes mal wirklich das erste mal dass
ich das ausprobiert habe auf der autobahn gefahren gas gegeben gas gegeben gas bei gas gegeben bei
dem elektroauto aber ihr wisst was ich meine ja beschleunigt und und man konnte dann zwar
noch drücken aber es ist es ist wirklich ab 150 einfach nichts mehr passiert
hat sich bisschen weird champ angefühlt aber gut 150 bisschen wenig nur reicht voll und ganz
es gibt leute die sagen mehr als 100 auf der autobahn soll es eh nicht geben
150 reicht voll und ganz also wie gesagt ich bin eh nicht der große ich fahre auch
muss ich sagen ich fahre auch wobei ich sage ich fahre immer noch nicht wirklich gerne auto
aber ich fahre deutlich lieber auto mit dem jetzt als mit dem davor
und also 550 reicht voll und ganz gerade mit dem 500 e das ist so ein kleiner und
hat auch so eine leichtgängige lenkung auch bei 150 also viel schneller würde ich mit
dem gar nicht fahren wollen was hast du für eine tastatur auf der arbeit ich habe eine
ducky one skyline allerdings mit numpad num block nicht numpad num block mit num block also nicht
die hier sondern eine mit num block die sind auch irgendwelche gründen hier nicht drinne haben
also ich habe die nur mit num block die sieht auch die sieht auch ziemlich genauso aus meine
enter tasse hat normal denne meine enter tasse ist normal ok wusste gar nicht dass es da auch so
viele varianten von gibt ich glaube auch mittlerweile eine mäuse skyline
aber warum ist das so fucking schwer auf dieser seite eine tastatur zu finden
gibt es ihn denn mehr oder was die seite ist ja mal ultra shit
ja das sieht das sieht ganz gut aus meiner ja ja also mein hat ein bisschen andere farben
aber es ist im prinzip ist im prinzip so hier ja weil ich bin nicht sicher bin ob ich alle
diese buttons hier oben habe und ich habe ich habe deutsches tastatur layout ja aber so mehr
oder weniger die habe ich bisschen bisschen andere farben haben die haben die buttons aber
ansonsten finde ich ist echt eine super tastatur ich habe immer die bedenken bei der arbeit wenn
ich im büro sitze manchmal und tippe auf der tastatur wenn ich viel tippen muss dass es die
leuten drum herum wenn denn welche da sind auf den zack geht weil selbst wenn ihr eine mechanische
tastatur nimmt und da jetzt nicht die super klick klick lauten switches reinmacht sondern
auch mit den default switchen ist schon ein bisschen lauter also bei uns also in der firma
wo ich jetzt arbeite die geben also was man bekommt an tastaturen dort sind flache low
profile logitech tastaturen mit gummi gummi tasten also diese gummi wie nennt man das rubber
dome genau also diese klassischen dinger die sind halt sehr leise aber ich persönlich chat wie
sieht es bei euch aus mögt ihr low profile tastaturen ja oder nee komm wir machen mal
wir chat chat wir machen mal eine umfrage wir machen wir machen mal eine umfrage mal gucken
ob das chat erino kann mit der umfrage low profile keyboards low profile keyboard oder
schreibe tastatur das tatur log not log nein kann chat erino natürlich nicht sagt jetzt
können wir uns hier noch nicht mal zusammen den chat angucken ich blende den shit mal aus
hey das funktioniert nice haha aber ich kann nicht klicken lul na toll also es scheint aktuell zu
sein dass ja 50 50 ungefähr ja ungefähr ungefähr 50 50 also ehrlich gesagt ich mag
low profile tastatur nicht naja und zumindest diese tastatur habe ich schon seit jahren die
habe ich mir extra mal für die arbeit gekauft ich habe also ich habe auf der arbeit eine kombination
ist jetzt pock dafür ja pock ist dafür pock ist halt halt pock pock ist dass es gut ist
und not pock ist dass es nicht gut ist obviously muss versteht doch jeder sofort
nein es geht im incognito modus auch nicht mehr ich habe es ausprobiert und die habe ich mir
vor jahren hier gekauft und ich habe auf der arbeit die kombination eine g502 pro score so ein
teil dieses das fette ding also das habe ich als maus und ducky und die ducky und skyline habe
ich als tastatur muss sagen ist wirklich eine super kombination hier daheim habe ich meine ganz
normale wireless logitech tastatur logitech maus am start mit dem selbst auflade pad und
die tastatur mit rgb aber auf der arbeit brauche ich keine rgb also ich muss sagen mir ist meine
aktuelle maus lieber als die g502 ich habe aktuell eine logitech pro wireless weil die ist leichter
und ist wireless ja aber was an der mega nice ist ist dieser button hier und da kann man quasi
so den widerstand vom mausrad rausnehmen und dann kannst du das mausrad quasi mit 900 umdrehungen
die sekunde flitzen lassen für drei minuten und das das dreht sich wirklich eine minute wenn
das ordentlich an an stopp stupst eine minute ist vielleicht übertrieben ja doch doch wenn das
ordentlich anstuppst kann es sich durchaus minute drehen das mausrad gut gutes kugellager
also das finde ich ganz nice ist manchmal wenn man ewig lange pdf oder webseiten oder
irgendwelche verdrehe durch scrollen muss so ist es tatsächlich ganz praktisch ja die habe
ich mir nicht für die arbeit gekauft die habe ich hier mal als gaming maus im einsatz gehabt
und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht habe ich die sogar von der gamescom und logitech damals
gekriegt zum ausprobieren also war sogar umsonst und jetzt liegt sie bei mir auf der arbeit
mini tastaturen mag ich nicht also ich habe das schon mal mir angeguckt ja ich habe ja
ein paar kollegen die so quasi diese super mini tastaturen aber sprich wo kein numblock
drauf ist noch keine arrow keys drauf sind so die ganz ganz kurzen ich mag das nicht ich will
eine richtig ordentlich fette tastatur vor mir stehen am numblock vor allem vor allem weil
ich ich mag ja auch den numblock ich ich hämmer ja ich hämmer ja wirklich gerne auf die numblock
tastet zum befehle ausführen ja hier er soll blabla blabla noch mal durchlesen bäm gib ihm
leute ich glaube wir müssen den wall wir müssen wallpaper anpassen moment wir gucken
jetzt live zu wenn er wechselt ja das ist schon es ist schon bettgetheim gleich das hat der
wallpaper sofort erkannt das bettgetheim ist was nehmen wir dann für einen heute c++ ach ich
weiß nicht ok was was was nehmen wir für ein people people sleep wallpaper den normalen den
träumenden von linux den den den da nehmen wir jetzt der ist gut den da nehmen wir neutral den
nehmen wir heute haben wir nicht noch einer wo er abends fernseh guckt oder ist auch für sunset ist
das auch oder
ich bin echt müde es fack aber ich bleib noch eine stunde an hat keinen sinn wenn ich jetzt
penge das stimmt so mit meinem rhythmus nicht überein ich bin noch eine stunde da und dann
gehe ich boomer müde boomer schlafen wachsastri ich habe schon getrunken gerade aber schön schön
dass ihr dass ihr eure punkte alle so raushaut wie numblock alle numblock ist das beste ich
auch arrow keys und numblock benutze ich auch relativ oft ich muss sogar sagen ich
finde es ein bisschen blöd dass hier die meine meine logitech tastatur keine anzeige hat für
numblock deswegen habe ich da oben die anzeige ob ich numblock an oder aus habe weil ich selbst
zu blöd bin mir das zu merken und meine logitech tastatur der meinung war hey lasst uns mal bitte
eine led einsparen obwohl das gesamte ding rgb beleuchtet ist ja bei dir ich benutze numblock
ganz gern übrigens danke für die subs falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe kann sein ich war
so jetzt irgendwie zwanzig minuten am dauer schmetzen du du du du du du du oh nee nee heute
kein bitkom please ok lass uns so kommen wir gucken uns wieder besondere technikgadget 150
ok besonders besonders muss ja mittlerweile auch keine besonders positive sache mehr sein besonders
heißt er nur irgendwie so ein bisschen abweichend von so dem normalen lasst mal gucken ich wette mit
euch er zeigt wieder gadgets die abgerundete ecken haben und wo ich mir denke warum sollte
man sich sowas kaufen was hältst du von web 3 web 3 hat irgendwelche krypto geschichten keine ahnung
ich glaube von web 3 redet überhaupt keiner mehr das schon wieder out ich warte ich warte
erstmal auf web 4 heute zeige ich euch technikgadgets von denen ihr denken werdet so was gibt's und dann
werdet ihr denken ja klar macht irgendwie sinn dass es so was gibt alles unter 50 euro mit
einer ausnahme er tags sind eine feine sache es war ja klar dass irgendwie gleich die apple
geschichten kommen bei ihm um verlorene oder gestohlene dinge wiederzufinden und kaum etwas
wird mehr gestohlen als fahrräder und da kommt diese klingel ins spiel sie sieht komplett normal
aus sie klingt auch ganz normal und also ja ok ich mein ich wüsste jetzt nicht ob so eine normale
klingel aussieht aber ich würde wahrscheinlich kein verdacht schöpfen gesagt für 20 euro ist sie
nicht mal sonderlich hochwertig aber sie hat im inneren ein verstecktes fach in das genau ein
reinpasst und das ist ein ziemlich cleverer ort auf den diebe sicherlich nicht so schnell
kommen eben weil diese klingel so gewöhnlich aussieht und wenn der worst case dann eintritt
diebe sind cleverer als man denkt sobald sobald das erste bekannt wird die sind nicht blöd kann
man das eigene fahrrad mit einem apple gerät wiederfinden dieses schloss von abus hat einen
fingerabdrucksensor und es ist ziemlich selbst das würde ich gleich mal dem lockpicking lawyer
geben was der dazu sagt erklärt wofür der gut ist man legt den finger drauf und das schloss
geht auf und das von allen seiten und erstaunlich schnell hat das in akku hat das in akku und was
passiert wenn der akku leer ist
mir zwar nicht immer auf den allerersten versuch aber spätestens dann eigentlich beim zweiten
oder dritten ersatzschlüssel hat aber kein schlüssel das hat oben so ein kleines loch
aber ich weiß nicht ob das dann so der ortensinn macht wo man vielleicht nicht 20 schlüssel
herausgeben möchte das schloss wirkt super robust und wiegt etwa doppelt so viel wie
dass das robust wirkt ist ja schön und gut aber wenn ich eine sache vom lockpicking lawyer
gelernt habe ist dass die schlösser selten geknackt werden indem sie zerstört werden
sondern indem die sagen die schwächste stelle benutzt wird und das ist meistens nicht sich
irgendwie durch das schloss durchfräsen oder sowas sondern mit den nötigen skills das
ding halt aufmachen etwa nicht dass ich könnte aber wie ein smartphone es ist gegen wasser
geschützt mit einer ip68 zertifizierung im inneren das moment moment das schloss hat
eine schraube unten das ist schon was das schlösser die man einfach aufschrauben zertifizierung im
inneren ist eine batterie die für zehntausend öffnungen reicht bevor sie leer geht lässt sich
das schloss nicht mehr zumachen und verhindert dass es so für immer geschlossen bleibt ich
habe mal zu 50 euro bei amazon bekommen und ein link und das ist weißes wenn es leer geht
während es geschlossen ist und es hängt dann vielleicht am keller eingang oder so
produkten ist selbstverständlich in der video beschreibung und da ist auch ein link zu rhino
schild denn ihr neuestes produkt ist richtig cool dieses kleine weiche für die macht er gerne
textil kann man in eine hülle legen und somit jedes gerät umhängen und die landjahrt bänder sind
nicht nur mega schick und hochwertig man kann sie auch ganz einfach in der länge verstellen und
noch zusätzliche dinge dranhängen wie zum beispiel airpods oder ein airtag das ganze ist voll
kompatibel mit allen rhino schild hüllen von denen es ja hunderte mit coolen und anpassbaren
was? was das? das sieht aus wie ein netzwerkkabel was ich mir um den hals gehängt habe
ok es ist im prinzip werbung für rhino schild es sieht ohne scheiß aus wie k7 kabel was ich mir um den hals gehängt habe
ich möchte ich über einen geldbeutel reden ja seit jahren suche ich nach einem neuen kompakten
geldklipp weil mein alter ziemlich mitgenommen aussieht und gefundene reine leute ihr kennt mich
ja ihr wisst dass ich kein portemonnaie habe ja hab ich schon öfters erzählt sowas sowas habe
ich nicht dann nicht selbst also meine freundin schenkt ihr mir zum geburtstag dieser kompakte
geldbeutel von segret ist in mehreren farben erhältlich segret segret segret up hat diesen
segret ich hab schon was das für ein name man segret segret ok das sieht cool aus wenn er nicht
aufpasst schießt er eine kreditkarte quer durchs geschäft das vegan im leder und hat diesen
coolen karten rausschießmechanismus und das sieht nicht nur nett aus es ist auch tatsächlich
praktisch im alltag weil ich jetzt viel schneller und einfacher an die gewünschte karte komme
maximal fünf karten passen hier rein aber noch vier weitere im inneren des geldbeutels und dort
ist auch noch ein fach für scheine das jetzt nicht spektakulär aussieht aber seinen job perfekt
erfüllt da ich jetzt auch eine andere persönlich diesen geldbeutel schon seit vier jahren benutzt
und der immer noch top aussieht weiß ich das ganze ding ist auch ganz schön robust was veganes
leder hat er veganes leder gesagt er muss ja ich mein veganes leder kann ja schlecht von der
echten von einem echten tier sein
wo hast du deinen perso deine krankenkasse karte daheim warum soll ich dir immer mitschleppen also
das einzige was ich dabei habe also neben meinem rucksack mit notebook und so was in der richtung
also das einzige was ich in der tasche stecken habe ist ein schlüssel fertig habe ich nicht
habe mit schlüssel dabei sonst nichts ich habe ich habe manchmal noch irgendwie fünf oder zehn
euro einstecken und das war das handy habe ich entweder in der jackentasche oder in der
hemmtasche oder manchmal auch in der anderen hosentasche aber was ich also das einzige was
ich immer in der hose stecken habe ist es hört sich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen falsch an ich
weiß ja aber ist tatsächlich der schlüssel
apple pay benutze ich auch apple pay ist tatsächlich enorm nützlich
hätte ich auch noch vor einem jahr nicht gedacht dass ich mal regelmäßig apple pay verwende aber
ich verwende mittlerweile apple pay wo man apple pay nur verwenden kann weil apple pay muss ja
nicht mehr direkt unterstützt werden das reicht ja schon halbwegs modernes oder es ist ja nicht so
dass die schreiben müssen wir akzeptieren apple pay es reicht schon jeder mehr oder weniger
aktuelle kartenleser dafür und das hat ja haben wir die meisten geschäfte wenn es nicht grad die
dörner der dörner an der ecke ist oder irgendwie der grieche an der ecke so so kleine oder kiosk
oder so bei kiosk haben oftmals auch kartenzahlung also so kleine so kleine imbesdinger haben keine
kartenzahlung aber die allermeisten bisschen größeren sachen haben wir mittlerweile kartenzahlung
und da hält man einfach sein smartphone dran und gutes tippste zweimal an hältst dran zack
also hätte paypal sowas auch würde ich auch paypal benutzen
muss man sich nicht immer ausweisen können ja schon aber nicht um was sind das hier
wie kriege ich denn das wieder weg
ok du musst dich schon ausweisen können aber du musst dich nicht unmittelbar vor ort irgendwie
hier hole ich den ausweis raus also im zweifelsfall wenn die dir das gar nicht glauben müssen sie
dich halt heimbringen und du kannst es denen zeigen also du musst es nicht dabei haben
du hast dir heute ein sehr suboptimalen tag ausgesucht falls du dir irgendwelche
technikgeschichten angucken willst wir machen nichts ich bin übelst kaputt ich bin in 40 min
auch wieder auf
ich sag auch immer mit karte bezahlen ich würde auch nicht sagen mit apple pay die meisten da
können überhaupt nichts mit apple pay anfangen wenn du am edeka sagst ich möchte mit apple pay
bezahlen verstehen die nicht wenn du sagst kartenzahlung zack handy dran gehalten gut ist
dann halt apple pay
richtig genau und ich hatte jetzt auch lange zeit ein nicht gültigen ausweis aber mittlerweile
habe ich gültigen ausweis also insofern ist es auch kein problem
feifert ne heute kein kubernetes aber wir machen die nächsten tage tatsächlich weiter mit unserem
kubernetes google cloud projekt letztes mal haben wir hier alles automatisiert mit terraform
provisioned provisioned provisioned provisioned und als nächstes machen wir ein bisschen kubernetes
konfig und zwei demo apps lasst mal kurz das video fertig gucken akkuschrauber sind jetzt nichts
habe ich mal ausprobieren hat mir nicht gefallen ich habe mal von irgendwie ich glaube ich glaube
auch schaumy war der grauer habe ich meine ausprobieren war das doch glaube schaumy hat
mir nicht gefallen ob ich wird zurückgeschickt wobei meine auch nicht gut war also du musst
es erst anfangen zu drehen und dann hat er automatisch weiter gedreht und so das hat
mir überhaupt nicht gefallen also ich muss sagen ich bin äußerst zufrieden mit also so
als multi multifunktions schraubendreher ich habe so einen viel zu teuren da habe ich mir
tatsächlich was ganz gutes gegönnt ich habe hier so einen und wie heißt das ding einen pb pb swiss
tools moment hier klick klick pb so ein mit ratsche hier hört mal leute mit ratsche das
richtig ist richtig richtig nice ich weiß ja hört ihr das ja vera toolcheck habe ich auch
wenn man wenn man wirklich vielfalt brauche ist das toolcheck ganz praktisch aber hört ihr hier
so die die die ratschenfunktion vom schraubendreher ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch man kann es aber
auch feststellen dass es es ohne uns nicht so als es ist ein da habe ich mir wirklich mal was
gegönnt ich glaube das habe ich mir sogar zu weihnachten gekauft damals vor drei vier jahren
das ist ein pb ist ne pb 65 ja der da ist es glaube ich
ja genau dieses teil ja korrekt dieses ding das ist wirklich nice also der ist das der hat den
grad zu feststellen und du kannst den so als ratsche ratsche funktionen benutzen aber was ich
tatsächlich ganz nice finde ist wie sie das hier hinten gemacht haben da passt zwar nicht so viel
rein aber du musst nicht so viel fummeln ja du hast hier so ein ding mit ausgeklappt raus zack
vorne rein zu und das ding ist halt auch stabil ja du kannst da ne der ist besser als der linux
technik das glaube ich somit eines der besten die ich bisher in der hand hatte fühlt sich auch
wirklich mega nice an sehr stabil obwohl es eine ratschenfunktion hat merkst du keinerlei
spielraum es ist sehr sehr fein gängig auch das ding kann ich wirklich empfehlen er ist nicht
ganz billig aber wie gesagt ich habe mir vor ein paar jahren zu weihnachten gekauft mal kurz
gucken was das teil aktuell kostet also wenn eine wirklich mal sich was gönnen will dann
weil man kann sich sagen hey guck mal da und kann sagen ich habe
ob das wirklich der richtig ist weil 48 wäre wirklich sehr günstig ich glaube ich habe auch
mehr bezahlt hey das ist tatsächlich relativ günstig ich kenne diesen ich kenne diesen laden nicht
ist das denn ist ja das ist das ist tatsächlich ein ganz guter preis glaube ich also wenn er
der bock hat 50 euro auf geht's kommt mal der rest ist ein bisschen teurer also ich finde den ich
finde den toll ich benutze den mittlerweile als default schraubendreher für alles was ich mache
es sei denn ich brauche was kleines wo man damit nicht reinkommt also das passiert aber relativ
selten das ist gar nichts ein ja zum beispiel in dem ikea in diesem ikea luftqualitätssensor
da musste ich mal rumschrauben da habe ich den natürlich nicht genommen da habe ich so
ein kleines so einen kleinen feinen mechanik schraubendreher aber wenn ich irgendwo was
schrauben muss und ich weiß noch nicht genau was dann nehme ich den und zu 95 prozent der fälle
kommst du damit super klar und du hast dank diesem fach hier drinnen auch das wichtigste
dabei man muss es ja übrigens das ist ganz das ist ein ganz normaler ganz normaler standard form
fakte also ihr könnt ja da auch bits reinsetzen die ihr wollt ihr müsst ja nicht die standard
bits nehmen weil die standard bits machen jetzt auch von der qualität ja ganz ganz ganz okay
ein eindruck ja und ich habe die standard bits drinne aber man kann also standard bits sind okay
du hast zwei zwei unterschiedlich große ja zwar genau also zwei unterschiedlich große wie nennt
man da wie nennt man die normalen schrauben die schlitzschrauben wie heißt denn das die
haben doch die haben doch so die halt die heißen doch irgendwie speziell die nennt man die schlitz
schrauben also zwei normale schlitzschrauben dann hat man glaube ich zwei torx und dann noch
dann noch diesen torx mit stern wo ich nicht genau weiß wie die heißt davon hast du noch
vier stück und zwei kreuzschlitz philips genau ja ja die meine ich die meine ich also hast
eigentlich so alles dabei was du so brauchst die könnten ein bisschen bessere webseite haben ja
hier sieht man sehr was dabei ist talk security genau ja und ich habe den jetzt bestimmt schon
paar hundert mal auf und zu gemacht ja hier die sind diese klappe das fühlt sich vielleicht am
anfang ein bisschen wackelig an es ist aber null wackelig wirklich geil und es ist mega stabil das
kann man nicht mehr abbrechen das haus dazu zack hast du super ordentlichen schrauben also
wie gesagt habe ich vor ein paar jahren mal zu weihnachten gekauft und das ist mittlerweile
mein die fall schrauber für alles wo man schrauben muss
so dass wir das wird fertig schauen ja was haben wir sonst noch ein also mit dem ding
kommst ja schon mal prinzipiell nirgendswo rein das sieht eher aus wie den mini akku schrauber
der nix kann besonderes aber einen elektrischen schraubenzieher habt ihr bestimmt noch nicht
gesehen und dann noch so ein schicken dazu hat vorne ein led so ein ding doch das sowas in der
richtung hatte ich mal von schaumi das hat mir also also meine muss ich dran drehen dass der
weitergedreht hat das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen ring lohnt sich der wenn man schon
ein i-fixi toolkit hat lohnen ist immer so ein schwieriges wort in dem fall weil man kann ja
prinzipiell nicht genug werkzeug haben also wahrscheinlich nicht
ich würde halt sagen dass i fixe toolkit ist tatsächlich nicht so robust wie der wie das
pb-swiss ding und das ist auch für feinere sachen gemacht also
also ich würde zum beispiel mein nummern schild nicht mit dem mit dem i fixe toolkit
festschrauben wobei es wahrscheinlich ohne probleme auch gehen würde also mein nummern
schild habe ich zum beispiel festgeschraubt mit dem großen
ja dass das i fixe toolkit ist halt eher so für so kleine bastel kram gut haben wir hier im stream
auch schon verwendet oder wenn man wenn man das mainboard festschrauben muss im rechner oder
sowas aber bei wie gesagt mein nummern schild festgeschraubt habe ich mit dem großen doch
meins ist also ich meine nicht das nummern schild selbst ich meine nummern schild halter
festgeschraubt das nummern schild selbst das steckt man also rein und macht so einen komischen
klipse ding unten dran den nummern schild halter habe ich damit reingeschraubt oder egal also alles
alles was ich schrauben muss mache ich eigentlich mit diesem ding so lass mal fertig gucken hinten
also wie gesagt ich hatte sowas ähnliches mal war nicht mein fall und kann sich nicht nur in
beide richtungen drehen man kann ihn auch ganz normal manuell nutzen gedacht ist so ein elektrischer
schrauben ja hat aber da hast du doch guck mal seriously wie willst mit dem ding normal schrauben
du hast doch überhaupt gar keinen halt richtig du hast doch gar keinen richtigen griff und ich
wette mit euch wenn du damit wirklich mal was schraubst was auch fest ist und da ordentlich
mal richtig dran zerzt da machst du es wahrscheinlich noch kaputt wenn du es von hand schraubst manuell
nutzen gedacht ist so ein elektrischer schraubenzieher eher für feine arbeiten auf einer baustelle
werdet ihr sowas vermutlich nicht finden aber um ein notebook zu öffnen ikea möbel aufzubauen oder
etwas zu reparieren das ist das ist so ein typisches tool das ist ein typisches tool für
irgendwie passt aus das typisches apple tool apple fan tool ich sage nicht dass es schlecht ist ich
kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass man damit arbeiten kann und sich cool vorkommen kann und
dass es auch irgendwie spaß macht aber mir persönlich glaube ich also den ich ausprobiert
habe gar nichts ich weiß nicht ich glaube mein fall ist nicht was was hast du ein mechaniker
präzision schraubendreher set oder ist das das sieht schon ziemlich ziemlich billig aus wenn ich
ehrlich bin
hallo
ich muss sagen das sieht schon ziemlich billig aus seriously ein komplettes
ein komplettes werkzeug set für 17 euro das kann eigentlich nix taugen
ich meine du kannst damit sicherlich das meiste das meiste machen aber
das ist halt die frage wenn du mal ordentlich daran siehst wie es danach ausschaut
von welchem hersteller ist das kennt man die ja klingt gerade kenne ich nicht
weiß nicht ich hätte mir nicht gekauft das ist alles absolut möglich und geht deutlich
schneller von der hand als ein gewöhnlicher schraubenzieher der lieferumfang ist gigantisch
groß und wirklich durchdacht ganze 56 bits eine kleine halterung für den schrauber selbst ein
ohne scheiß das wäre mir viel zu viele filigranes rum gefickt zu filigranes rum
gefricke bis ich anfangen könnte zu schrauben wenn ich was schrauben will dann nehme ich
entweder die die schrank hier hinter mir auf die an die an die wand mit dem werkzeug und
nehme den passenden raus meistens dann eben so ein kleines fein mechanikdingen wenn ich
was kleines machen will raus und fangen zu schrauben oder ich nehme den großen der
hat standard mich in kreuzschlitz bitte drinnen der geht geht für 80 prozent der fern ansonsten
tauschen schnell auf zack weiter also das wäre mir viel zu filigranes rum gefuddelt mit diesem
teil bis ich anfangen könnte was zu machen und aber gut apple leute die erstmal keine ahnung
fünf minuten das einlegen eines bits zelebrieren wollen die freuen sich
da wahrscheinlich drüber und und alles passt in diese beiliegende bock
die gleichzeitig als ablage dient für 50 euro bekommt man hier echt was geboten und ich freue
mich jetzt wie viel ablage dient für 50 ohne scheiß leute für 50 euro kauft euch das ding
gerade im angebot in dem shop was ich euch gezeigt habe hier also ok ich gebe zu es sind
beide nicht in der gleichen tja anwendungskategorie das ist eher so eine soll man sagen so eine
spielerei für vielleicht eher so ein bisschen elektronik feinere sachen wobei richtig feinere
sachen kann sie damit ja auch nicht machen sagen bisschen für elektronik und feinere sachen ja
und das das ding das ding was ich euch hier gezeigt habe das ist ja schon ein bisschen
bisschen heftiger da habt ihr was in der hand also wenn ihr euch gehen mal gegen einbrecher
verteidigen müsst könnt ihr damit auch machen das sind vielleicht nicht die komplette kategorie
aber ganz ehrlich für 50 euro wenn man was zum schrauben braucht kauft das und 50 euro
wirklich guter preis ich glaube ich habe 70 oder so dafür bezahlt also das auch wirklich
massiv das einzige was euch vielleicht stören könnte wenn ihr damit ein bisschen feinere sachen
machen wollt also wenn ihr durch feinere öffnungen müsst dass euch das hier vielleicht hier vorne
ein bisschen zu dick ist den hatte ich die grunde ist er das
nee weil er war grau aber ich hatte also ich hatte von schaumi ein vielleicht gab es ja
dann mal sagt second generation was du gepostet hast hier das ja auch second generation war ja
die first gen ich habe das mal ausprobiert just for fun habe das glaube ich bei notebook billiger
damals bestellt mit irgendwas anderem ich glaube ich habe damals sieben steckdosen bestellt und
hatte irgendwie so ein ding mal mitbestellt bei notebook billiger damals noch und das hat mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen das stimmt das ist eine gute kombination das ist tatsächlich du wirst
lachen das ist exakt die kombination die ich auch bei mir am start habe ich habe ich habe
den i fix it kit man muss halt sagen mit dem tool check plus dem i fix it du hast schon ein
bisschen überlappung ja also vieles kannst du mit dem einen oder mit dem anderen machen aber ich
habe ich habe ich habe für unterschiedliche aber in so ein bisschen unterschiedliche vorleben also
genau das habe ich auch ich habe das i fix it toolkit ich habe den tool check plus und ich
habe dieses pb-swiss ding was ich dann was ich da noch zusätzlich habe ist ich habe noch einen
vera torx set wobei vor ich jetzt laber man sieht es doch hier in dem video
bisschen werkzeug flex ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man ja hier sieht okay man sieht
ein bisschen man sieht ein bisschen man sieht nicht man sieht nicht alles ja ich
habe noch so einen so einen vera torx set weil wenn wenn man was was schrauben muss viele
sachen heute sind ja tatsächlich torx und da hast du echt was in der hand also da kannst du
auch wirklich mal so ein bisschen bisschen dran rumwürgen an dem zeug bis es locker ist ja man
sieht auch kaum an dem großen sieht man vielleicht ein bisschen man sieht auch kaum irgendwelche
abnutzungen sowas da kannst du da kannst du dich wirklich daran aus da ich habe so wie gesagt
so ein vera torx ding sondern habe ich noch den tool check plus der hängt hier unten und hier
unten ist das i fix it toolkit den anderen sieht man hier sieht man hier gerade gerade nicht
bosch 1215 oder 1235 ich glaube was sind das für einer sieht man das glaubt das sind 35 oder
also warum mache ich kein werkzeug flex im video moment moment wusste wusste werkzeug flex
ist jeder werk ist jeder werkzeug flex ok moment ja wer wäre joker joker schlüssel set mit
ratchenfunktion ich glaube das ist das teuerste werkzeug was ich mir gekauft habe total unsinnig
ich benutze das einmal im jahr aber ich wollte es haben weil ich mir gedacht habe ich will halt
willst halt haben so also einmal oder maximal zweimal im jahr ja genau also das ist also ja
ist das vera joker schlüssel 2 mal im jahr für also ich kann euch sagen ich kann euch sagen was
ich das weiß ich das die sind tatsächlich nicht ganz nach größe sortiert die haben einfach so
reingesteckt das letzte was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe damit den tisch auf dem ich manchmal
elektronik kram streame da wurde das wo es ein bisschen gewackelt hat den tisch habe ich
wieder festgezogen damit und da war es tatsächlich äußerst praktisch dass ich diese ratchen
ratchenfunktion hier auf der seite hatte weil unten an dem tisch kannst du überhaupt nicht
richtig ansetzen aber du kannst es einmal dran machen und festmachen so das ist das vera elektronik
set auch recht praktisch wenn man wenn man mal was braucht brauchst eigentlich relativ selten ist
aber das erste was ich mir von vera gekauft habe das ist glaube ich das ist glaube ich das ist mit
das älteste was hier hängt so dass i fix it set dann habe ich noch so ein paar bild die habe ich
die habe ich auch schon jahrelang die sind auch schon ziemlich abgenutzt und kaputt wenn man sieht
dass das war eben so ein billig so billiges fein mechanik set mal formen wenn ich vom lidl
oder sowas wahrscheinlich das habe ich das habe ich 20 jahr oder so habe ich wirklich schon ewig
dort schulcheck plus beste gerade gerade wenn man wenn man die bits braucht hat man alle möglichen
bits mal dabei und man hat noch mal zusätzlichen bit aufsatz wechsler die dinger sind auch sehr
sehr praktisch und ab und zu braucht man immer panöse um irgendwas zu schrauben kommt kommt aber
relativ selten vor haben wir vom oba noch das ist ja aggro schrauber obendrüber ja ja max wir haben
es super der aggro schrauber zeigen wir gar nicht was ist es denn für einer ich vermute 1235 sieht
man das natürlich nicht genau dann habe ich noch die wo ich mir immer nicht merken kann ob
es im bus oder im bus schlüssel heißt ach ja und das hier ist tatsächlich man sieht es jetzt nicht
richtig das ist mega praktisch wenn man 3d wenn man 3d getrocknet 3d trocke macht das sind so
stufenbohrer habe ich mich beraten lassen vom chat heißt das nicht kegelbohrer sind stufenbohrer
da kann man so schöne abgerundete löcher in 3d gedruckte sachen rein schnüppeln
ja sowas also also während 3d während 3d trocke hat und da schön abgerundete löcher
rein bekommen wollen die dinger sind sowas in der richtung ist es sehr nice ja hier da in der
ecke hängt ab isoliert champ der darf natürlich nicht fehlen die haben wir schon öfters hier
im stream benutzt und dann haben wir noch ein paar zangen und und eisluft ganz wichtig der
eisluft champ kabel zeug ja so ein elektronik ding ja da hatte ich den pbs was wohl ich hängen
gerade ja wenn schon wenn wenn schon dann was gescheites leute wenn schon was gescheites
darf sein arsch neu aufsetzen warum hast du kein back-up
ist der vms und snapshots sind sehr praktisch
wird man wieder zeit für l-video ja ich wollte euch ja noch mein auto mal zeigen in dem video
wird ich glaube es wird mal zeit für 4500 e-stells oder was meint ihr wird wird glaube ich mal wird
glaube ich mal zeit ich glaube davon habe ich die habe ich tatsächlich auch schon mal gesehen in
irgendeinem vorstellungsvideo was auch relativ was auch relativ gut sein soll preisleistungstechnisch
für knarren für so ein knarren set ist wie heißt die proxon gibt es sowas prox kom proxon
heißen die glaube ich das ist so so grüne grüne kisten sieht aus wie von meinem proxon genau sieht
aus wie von meinem opa aber das soll preisleistungstechnisch auch recht gut sein
hast du auch kunststoff seitenschein mit bündnischen nein also nicht nicht das ist mir bewusst wäre
so lass uns mal kurz fertig gucken
sicherlich nicht einfach nur für die lobobs für uns die seilen das absolut design erreicht
die größe passt in jeden rucksack oder koffer und im inneren sind dank dem zia monika aufbau
über 20 fächer jedes kabel speicherkarten ich muss sagen das sieht tatsächlich ganz praktisch
aus klatten kopfhörer netzteile wenn ich filme einige nd filter oder etwa ein apple pencil passend
bequem rein ich hatte da drin aber auch schon alltagsgegenstände wie sonnencreme oder sie
sieht tatsächlich ganz praktisch aus ja in meiner erfahrung sind peek design produkte
immer hochwertig gebaut und bestehen ist auch die seile materialien außerdem sind sie mit
anderen pick design produkten kompatibel und das bedeutet packer die taschen müssen schon
kompatibel zueinander sein ist einfach so dass man den rucksack von dem hersteller tasche von
dem hersteller und keine ahnung den gürtel von dem hersteller und eine kappe von dem das geht
nicht das muss peek design muss alles inter connected werden dass ich diese tasche außen an
meinem rucksack befestigen kann oder mit meinem kamera gurt sie umwandeln kann in eine umhängetasche
kostenpunkt 69 euro welches gadget hat euch am besten gefallen schreibt mir das gerne in
die kommentare oder macht aber muss ich muss ich jetzt mal witzbar sein macht tatsächlich
einen ganz praktischen eindruck habt ihr selbst und ich muss auch sagen ich finde die tasche
sieht optisch auch ganz gut aus und macht zumindest im video einen stabilen und als lässt sich auch
nicht so einfach wenn du dich mal aus versehen drauf setzt hast du nicht gleich aus versehen
den den den den traum dreher in poppens stecken weil sich durch piekst oder mit meinem kamera gurt sie
umwandeln kann in eine umhängetasche kostenpunkt 69 euro welches gadget hat euch am besten gefallen
schreibt mir das gerne in die kommentare oder habt ihr selbst tatsächlich tatsächlich die tasche
der rest war jetzt nicht so mein fall wir gucken es jetzt kein 3d drucker tutorial an das krieg ich
jetzt zu alt zu high iq jetzt kann ich nicht sicher tunnel to all your apps ich gehe mal
davon aus er benutzt den klaut den klaut flair wie heißt das ding klaut flair nee
nach kann und wieder klaut flair tunnel heißt aber aber er scheint klaut flair zu benutzen
was sagst du nix habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert lass mal eine open source tasche machen ja was
willst du an der tasche open source machen die das layout und das und die lizenz dann und
oder wenn du dir get clones hast du eine tasche oder wie soll das funktionieren
aber ja ja chat macht ihr macht ihr ruhig eine open source tasche auf geht's aber sonst
eigentlich was spannendes was wir uns angucken können
kenn i make money kenn i make my money starting bis das achter macht ihr jetzt 3d drucker
geschichten juckt mich nicht hier stehen über 300 server vor 33 minuten leute akuma er war auch
jetzt das gucken wir uns an aber nicht jetzt 33 minuten ist zu lang das kann er jetzt nicht
mehr machen der asozialste typ im internet da sieht er nicht es gibt noch kein facebook oder
instagram keine iphone das muss klatschen das ist mir jetzt aber auch zu lang leute ich muss
echt gleich ins bett ich penne gleich ein was bist du bei hetzer wie
ich arbeite nicht bei hetzer was soll was soll ich bei hetzer sein
wann gar nicht soll ich bei hetzner moin leute ich bin tim ach ja von denen hat man nicht
was soll was soll ich bei hetzer im rechenzentrum nicht dass mich nicht
dass mich da irgendwie hinzieht kann man nicht dass sie mich einladen würden aber ich hätte
eigentlich gesagt gar keinen großen bock er kennt mich ich mache keine real life videos
und wenn muss ich aufpassen dass ich mich 30 mal spiegel ich glaube ich kein bock drauf aber
was wir wieder machen könnten ist in hetzner cloud stream da müssen wir uns was cooles
überlegen wir könnten vielleicht man einen kubernetes cluster bei hetzner machen selbst
aufsetzen bei denen mit mit irgendwie drei vms oder vielleicht könnte man über die hetzner api
sogar da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher ob das irgendwie supported ist zumindest out of the box
vielleicht sogar sein cluster auto scale lassen die armkisten sind mega doppelte leistung für
den gleichen preis ist das wirklich doppelte leistung du bekommst doppelte kerne für den
gleichen preis oder für ist aber du bekommst doppelt so viel kerne und ein bisschen mehr
ram für den gleichen preis aber ist die performance wirklich doppelt so viel weil
je nachdem was es für armenkerne sind ist so ein x86 auch mit acht kerne war schneller als
ein 16 kerne armenkiste
ok aber vielleicht ok doppelte aber vielleicht nur in ganz speziellen benchmarks oder aber es
wäre natürlich sinnvoll gut das können wir uns tatsächlich mal angucken das video von ihm
zeige mal her youtube
also wenn es raspberry pies sind muss man sagen raspberry pies sind nicht sonderlich
schnell also so ein raspberry pie stinkt ziemlich ab gegen ordentlich x86 kiste
ich grüße euch das hier
würdest du es mal in erwegung ziehen ein bisschen extra action habe ich noch
nichts mitgemacht also ich kann mir anhand des namens grob vorstellen ja was es was es ist
also ich würde sagen es klingt nach so ein bisschen wie nennt man das automatisierte
art capture the flag geschichte oder so eine automatisierte ja teste wie wie weit du kommst
und da irgendwelche challenges rauszubekommen sowas in der richtung ja so versuche rauszubekommen
wie sich hier auf hier in der datenbank liegt irgendwas drinne und wie kriegst du da zugriff
irgendwie sowas in der richtung würde ich mir vorstellen vom namen her habe ich aber nicht
noch wirklich gar nichts mitgemacht den vorgefertigten ausführen was was die
schwachstellen ist ja ok sowas in der richtung erinnert mich ein bisschen ans jetzt aber was
muss um linux geschichten geht
was wem von wem ich habe keine ahnung von was ihr sprecht
kommt wir gucken das jetzt noch mal schnell mit schnell mit den raspberry pi ist also ich
bin ja skeptisch aber wie gesagt also wenn du raspberry pi versus nur nach 15 x86 kiste
antreten lässt stinkt der raspberry pi komplett ab aber aber das sind bestimmt keine raspberry
pies bei hetzner raspberry pies sind viel zu teuer dass ich bei hetzner in faltenstein
zu besuch im datacenter war und gleichzeitig diese ganze arm 64 architektur so ein bisschen
vorgestellt habe und letzte woche war es dann soweit hetzner hat halt eben diese arm 64
architektur in der cloud zur verfügung gestellt das heißt du ihr da draußen könnt jetzt ganz
normal diese arm 64 architektur in der cloud nutzen und ich habe mir einfach mal angeschaut
wie sieht es denn jetzt eigentlich mit dem sogenannten versprechen aus was hetzner uns
gegeben hat haben wir jetzt wirklich einen preis leistungsvorteil und das also wo wir
auf jeden fall einen preis leistungsvorteil haben ist bei beim ram verbrauch also nicht
beim ram verbrauch bei bei der menge wie viel ram man für das geld kriegt das hat man ja
gesehen das war deutlich besser also wer memory brauche fährt anscheinend mit dem arm mit den
armkisten wirklich besser schreibt auch hetzner bei sich auf der webseite das ist jetzt zwar unter
dem dedizierten server hier aber zwei wichtige sätze drunter einmal hier mit blick auf threads
und leistung sind zwei single threading cores einem x86 hyper threading core deutlich überlegen also
ihr müsst wissen ein arm 64 core sind ja auch zwei cores versus einen ja und wenn sich gut
parallelisieren lasst ok es kommt aber auch ein bisschen drauf an welcher kerne versus welche
kerne also wie gesagt wenn den raspberry pi nimmst und lässt den gegen den also den raspberry pi
wie viel wie viel hat der pi mittlerweile vier kerne ja und wenn er den gegen irgendwas halbwegs
aktuelles x86 antreten lässt das scheißt komplett ab es kackt wirklich komplett ab die die billigste
low power intel x86 platform ist ist deutlich schneller als ein raspberry pi nur mit einem
thread belegt wobei ihr kennt selber aber eurem pc ist hier zu hause die meisten von euch zumindest
haben eine ganz normale x86 architektur und unsere cpus heutzutage haben halt pro core zwei threads
und hier wird halt eben gerade einfach vorgerechnet dass zwei cores physikalische cores von arm 64
einem physikalischen core mit zwei threads in einer x86 architektur hätte er kann er an der
stelle auch viel sagen wenn der tag lang ist aber klingt klingt einleuchtend und das werden wir
jetzt halt eben testen aber viel wichtig es gibt noch einen zweiten satz und das ist dieser hier
dieser ansatz ermöglicht es strom zu sparen und die leistung pro watt zu steigern das stimmt wenn
es wenn es einem darum geht ist arm auf jeden fall besser also sagen wir so watt pro oder steht
leistung pro watt dürften die dinger jede x86 jede halbwegs schnelle x86 kiste in die tasche
stecken ja das denke ich auch wiederum die kosten ist halt die frage ob es mich interessieren sollte
als cloud kunde weil ich bezahle ja das was drauf steht klar sind das die preise für strom und so
was mit eingerechnet keine frage aber letztendlich wenn ich mit dem preis ok bin dann dann dann muss
mich eigentlich unterm strich nicht interessieren wie viel das jetzt brauche für die kunden
reduziert werden können das ist natürlich ein bisschen die frage habt ihr denn jetzt mehr
leistung beziehungsweise gleiche leistung für weniger preis ja oder nein und dem thema habe ich mich
mal so ein bisschen angenommen und halt jetzt einfach mal preis und denk wir können das so ein
ding auch mal ausprobieren formens der einzelnen cloud so ein bisschen mal entgegen und das gucken
einfach mal ausgerollt eine ganz normale die auf einem 4 kerne und einmal ein arm 64 mit 8 kernen
warum zeige ich euch auch ganz klar ich gehe jetzt einmal ein arm das ist tatsächlich finde
ich auch die beste die beste vm die sie haben falls das die ist falls das die 3 3 kerne hier
ram kiste ist das mal kurz gucken
nee ist es gar nicht ok hätte ich jetzt gedacht weil das ist ok das ist die die quad
kiste also preis leistungsmäßig finde ich persönlich die hier mit abstand am besten
du hast eine richtig gute kombination aus cpu power ist drei stück gut alternativ kann man
und mit 4 g ram kommst du mit den meisten sachen auch aus es sei denn du willst open
street view maps oder sowas machen wurde 96 brauche 64 mit acht kernen hetzler mittlerweile
auch in amerika ja die haben jetzt in esch börn oder wie das heißt auch heißt das so aber wir
ich habe sogar ein stream dazu gemacht als hetzler in die usa gegangen ist ja ja die haben mittlerweile
auch ein stadt und die haben die haben in finland was weiß gar nicht ob es richtig aus dem kopf
zusammen zwei in deutschland eins in usa eins in finland glaube wenn ich das wenn ich das richtig
zusammenbringen und ich glaube das rechenzentrum in wie heißt das jetzt der usa wo haben die denn
ihre esch börn sage ich doch
ach sie haben sogar die sind mittlerweile sogar zwei standorte in usa damals damals war es wo ich
das hier gezeigt habe im stream war es tatsächlich nur ein standort ja genau finland ich glaube
finland ist auch das rechten zentrum was komplett aus erneuerbaren energie betrieben wird gut ich
meine das ist in finland in finland haben die wahrscheinlich keine ahnung irgendwelche
generatoren im mehr und weiß ich ob es da irgendwie auch erdwärme wie in island gibt
ich glaube das hier ist das mit aus erneuerbaren energie in das rechenzentrum warum zeige ich euch
auch ganz klar ich gehe jetzt einfach mal was du hast doch mal eine erweiterung für monitor
geschrieben im stream weiß gerade noch ab time kuma war das benutze ich aber nicht mehr sach
faltenstein und wir gucken uns die maschinen hier ein viermal 50 und wenn wir jetzt einfach mal
zum 21 auch mit vier kernen und acht gigabyte ram um die ecke kommt ja der speicher unterscheidet
sich ein bisschen aber trotzdem hier ist der preis einfach weniger als die hälfte also ist das
zumindest unser performance vergleichbare system wobei ich natürlich auch gerne hingehen will und
diesen kax 31 mit euch vergleichen hat dann vier kors mehr aber der ist dann in der preis region
ganz normal von halt eben der amd epic maschine und damit hätten wir dann quasi unseren kleinen
preis leistungsvergleich also nehmen wir alle drei maschinen und werden die einfach so ein
bild haben für euch geöffnet auf der rechten seite extra mal arm architektur ihr seht ja hier ich
spule mal ein bisschen vor mal gucken was rauskommt das ist der arm 64 klein mit vier kors und das
hier ist der arm 64 schuldigung amd 64 der läuft hier auf dem amd epic in der cloud und da sehen
wir jetzt auch schon die ergebnisse die haben wir 16.000 events die halt eben in was macht
er denn überhaupt für den benchmark was ist denn das prime numbers bis 10.000 jetzt ja nix
10.000 prime numbers das rechnest du ja fast im kopf in der geschwindigkeit übertrieben gesagt
da also muss man also würde ich ja schon mal ein bisschen längeren bett ich glaube da macht auch
ein bisschen also ein bisschen längere benchmarks als als zehn sekunden werden schon nicht verkehrt
zehn sekunden bearbeitungszeit schafft versus 33.000 events die er in zehn sekunden bearbeitungszeit
schafft auf dem arm 64 jetzt nicht sofort aufschrecken und sagen wow das ding ist ja doppelt so schnell ja
in diesem test ist das lässt sich aber muss man muss mal der fernis halber sagen ich glaube das
ist auch eine sache die sich halt mega gut parallelisieren lässt aber es ist schon mal
eine hausnummer das ist jetzt gerade so aber das ist halt einfach ein test mit einem befehlsatz
wo einfach diese arm 64 architektur einfach ein stück weit überlegen ist aber wir wollen natürlich
noch ein bisschen mehr vergleichbarkeit reinbringen und da empfiehlt sich einfach mal so ein 7zip
benchmark durchlaufen zu lassen das ist jetzt wirklich alles 7zip selber hat so eine art benchmark
tool mit on board wo jetzt wirklich hingeht und was ist das eigentlich für benchmark bei
super computer für diese top 100 weiß gar nicht was sie da benchmarken einfach irgendwelche
pseudodaten floating point operations oder irgendwas keine ahnung was sie da benchmarken
und halt eben auch wieder die komprimiert und da sehen wir halt eben auch die anzahl an millions
ich glaube millions instruction per seconds die halt eben dann ganz normal die systeme können auch
hier wieder rechts oben schaut mal die cpus müssen halt das sind aber das sind tatsächlich
also das sind schon faire benchmarks kann man nicht sagen das sind aber halt auch wirklich
dass ich mega gut parallelisieren ja eben wirklich bei diesem test aber wenn man so was wenn man so
was hat ist natürlich gut dieser test wackelt auch zwei drei verschiedene sachen durch und
macht nicht nur dasselbe und da können wir jetzt mal sehen was wir dafür ergebnisse haben im
average wert haben wir jetzt hier unten bei der architektur 16,272 millionen instructions per
second und hier unten bei der amd epic haben wir jetzt halt 15,9 das heißt bei nicht so viele
unterschieds jetzt schon ein bisschen anders aus da sind wir halt eben einfach absolut vergleichbar
und das ist auch das was ich euch eben schon sagen wollte ist wir können uns nicht nur auf
einen test halt eben verlassen wir müssen mehrere sachen machen weil cpus können natürlich nicht
nur man muss vor allem sich überlegen was man machen will also wenn man jetzt was hat was sich
nicht so gut parallelisieren lässt kann das durchaus sein dass man in der x86 kiste wiederum
besser fährt es ist wie so oft in der it es kommt drauf an ein befehlssatz sondern deutlich
mehr befehlssätze abarbeiten und da fällt mir eigentlich sofort ein lasst uns einfach mal so
ein geek benchmark test machen denn der macht ja wirklich verdammt verdammt viel und nicht nur
so vereinzelt irgendeinen cpu stress test oder so compression und decompression test das hat
ich ganz interessant ja vergleichste kiste hier unten laut zeitweite sogar das doppelte an
performance wie gesagt die auch gerade voll belastet werden ein stück weit sogar das doppelte an
performance wie gesagt jetzt bei den schlechten und decompression test von so das ist auch der
compression test doppelte performance für denselben preis ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt wir müssen
so ein bisschen mehr vergleichbarkeit reinschaffen und der geekbench ist eine ziemlich ziemlich gute
sache dank meiner community die auch gefunden hat dass auch der geekbench für die arm 64 oder
arch 64 architektur auch vor zur verfügung steht habe ich den einfach mal heruntergeladen und
jetzt können wir wirklich sehen der komplette geekbench wird jetzt ja einfach mal durchlaufen
recht seht er jetzt auch dass die einzelnen tests jetzt einzeln die cpus belasten und jetzt gleich
kriegen wir wirklich auf der geekbench webseite ja mal so ein bisschen mehr vergleichbarkeit rein
um zu sehen und sagen zu können nachher alles klar welche cpu ist denn jetzt wie für mich geeignet
und ist das hetzner versprechen weiterhin die geekbench mark sind jetzt alle durchgelaufen und
ich habe direkt hier mal die kompärsicht für uns aufgerufen alles was blau ist jetzt hier ist
der arm 64 vierkern alles was graues ist dieser amd epic vierkern und jetzt können wir nicht so
wirklich viel unterschiede deutlich sehen bei diesen tests die der geekbench hier fährt haben
wir wirklich so in etwa 10 prozent delay zwischen der arm 64 architektur versus der x86 architektur
die auf den amd epic drauf liegt und das ganze sind hier so ja auch ziemlich genau in dem fall
jetzt hier es ist mehr oder weniger gleich auf könnte man sagen ich meine der sind mehr punkte
besser leute sind mehr punkte besser oder sind weniger sind das sekunden also wenn das eine
zeit ist dann ist weniger dann ist weniger besser 100 punkte was meines erachtens ja noch echt geht
und wir gar nicht so stark merken würden und gerade halt eben in summa summarum untenrum beim
multicore sehen wir sogar nur in summe wie gesagt 200 punkte die uns dort fehlen was wirklich dann
aber guck mal das single core tester ist gar nicht so viel schneller der epic also da haben
die schon ordentliche armen kisten stehen ram also ram bekommst du bekommst du mehr ja also
für ram lastige sachen lohnt sich auf jeden fall ich mal fünf prozent wirklich sind wenn
man da mal so ein bisschen weiter durchscrollen sieht man halt ganz gut wo liegen vielleicht mal
schwächen ja ok aber ist doch vollkommen in ordnung ich glaube wir sollten das auch mal
ausprobieren kann kann sich durchaus lohnen also muss man muss man tatsächlich auch mal
ausprobieren vielleicht nutze ich in zukunft auch ein bisschen mehr armen kisten so mal kurz
vergleichen so paar klassen prices so schert hier x86 haben wir glaube ich letztens schon
mal geguckt man war die ip war die publik ip aus die brauchen wir nicht unbedingt so nehmen
mal meine meine lieblingskiste meine lieblingskiste für 8 euro 39 ok 8 euro 39 bekommste 4 gigabyte ram
und gucken wir mal was es bei arm gibt nehmen wir gut nehmen wir die nächste ja kriegste doppelt
so viel ram ja dafür da ist immer ist dann schlecht da ist dann schlecht ich würde mal sagen
leistungstechnisch sollten wir allerdings mit drei x86 course vier armen course bisschen überlegen
sein je nachdem was man macht aber auf jeden fall meistens dürfte es nicht wirklich ins
gewicht fallen und hier bekomme ich für den gleichen preis 4 gigabyte ram mehr muss man
eigentlich lang überlegen oder ist aber super geschichte und die achter sogar bis du bist du
16 das ist das ist nicht schlecht also also für sieben euro sieben euro ist finde ich auch ein
ziemlich guter preis für so was was man im monat mal bezahlen kann sieben euro 8 g ram 4 course
doch top bei google bezahlst du für eine popel vm schon 35 euro im monat
also eine vm in der richtung google cloud bezahlt 35 euro aber die preise bei google für vm sind
auch wirklich jenseits von all dem was man machen sollte und kann ich kaufen sollte wenn man vor
eims braucht
aber interessant mal zu sehen ich glaube wir probieren das auch in nächster zeit mal aus
leute ich gehe pennen ich bin müde als fack wir sehen uns morgen oder die tage bis denn see you